it's the middle of the night here in
western Sydney and eager Star Wars fans
are lining up for the start of what
Disney is calling force Friday thanks to
international time zones the global
rollout of toys for the latest in the
Star Wars movie saga starts here no the
movie isn't due out for another three
months yes it's shameless merchandising
and no these people don't care no not at
all good on Disney well I'm really
looking for a figurines of the new movie
I just try to find out a little more a
little bit more about the story what's
going on and sometimes it's dude there's
a few tips hit in with the packaging and
everything and it's just a great way to
celebrate the passion you know in 2013
Star Wars products generated more than
two billion dollars in retail sales as
the high builds around the seventh movie
in the franchise it's likely that number
will be blown out of the water this year
especially as the much-loved characters
from the original trilogy make a return
Chewie we're home and on the track these
toys could potentially be worth big
money in January an action figure of
Boba Fett from the original Star Wars
trilogy sold for twenty eight thousand
dollars the Star Wars fans here might
have to wait 40 years to find out if
this a new merchandise becomes
collectible it's more likely they'll get
a solid workout is toys all Ellen
Bloomberg Sydney